and we say she's following the example
of Mary the mother of Jesus they see you
what's called a hijab they say she's
subjugated she's oppress what do you say
to that when you hear that you know from
my experience working for the city
covering I get more respect when I was
with the city working for the city one
of the officials came up to me and say
you know I think you are dressed most
beautifully why because the way I dress
it makes me respect me more and it makes
the people around me respect me when
they see me they don't see her jab they
see me they're looking at me
because I respect myself and I never
ever but take off my head jab why
because this is who I am
this it makes me who I am you know I'm
63 years old and I've been wearing my
head jab for a long time and when you
work for city governments and you work
you have 1,000 employees and you're the
only one with her jab and people come by
you especially the men and say to you
how are you do you need anything
can I take this package from you can I
open the door for you this shows me that
God Himself Allah the one and only one
Alki you is with me why because against
all adversity I'm standing for Who I am
I'm not undressed because I'm afraid
that I won't get a job you know God gave
me the job nobody gave me the job but my
lord so when you feel Allah and you do
what Allah say and you follow what
Allah's words and you obey the Prophet
may peace be upon him who say be modest
cover yourself to protect yourself and
to take care for your husband not your
boyfriend not even your girlfriend for
your husband your modesty for yourself
oh let me tell you something
wearing this a [ __ ] I'm a superstar when
I don't wear my hijab I feel like I'm
nothing why because I'm not doing for
the people I'm doing it because I fear
my Lord and I'm obeying the greatest man
who ever lived
Prophet Muhammad sallallahu wasallam
that's deep you didn't expect all that
did you you guys want to say this last
thing about the hijab when you look at
the history and the great women of the
world who wore hijab you know we started
with our mother
marry then we started we look at mother
Teresa she was one of the most beloved
women in the world she wore her jab look
at our beloved nuns look at them
the nuns they all wear hijabs if you
look out through history back from
western days from you know if you want
to go from Pharaohs world the women wore
hijab they covered we cover a thousand
different ways but we are covered we are
modest what happened to us
now we don't wear hijab you have more
rapes you have more murders you have so
many bad things happen to women because
we're showing everything we got and
people are taking it from us you find
the Muslim women you know we're modest
and when I look at Mother Teresa
when I look at Mary Mother of Jesus may
peace be upon him when I look at all of
the nuns and these famous women who wore
her Jeff they are the most respected
women in history and that's in the Bible
in the Torah in the Quran you will find
these modest women you're getting a lot
of facts here you're learning a lot and
that's how you're gonna grow through the
proper knowledge making a connection
because I'm telling you it takes a lot
more energy harboring that hate and you
only shackle yourself and hold yourself
back but look you've already learned a
few things and that light bulb went on
aha they had aha moment even lied to a
lot of the times people are out there
trying to polarize separate us